last week I did a video about pedestrian
crossings and why don't this turn into
things you might not know about British
pedestrian crossings well there is one
more thing and quite a few people got in
touch to say I should point it out
there's a secret button or nodule on the
bottom of these things little things you
push when you want to cross the road and
what that little secret nodule is is a
sign for anyone who is blind and deaf or
partially blind and partially deaf or
who is partially blind another crossing
that does not make a beeping noise when
it's safe to cross which is a surprising
amount of crossings because that little
nodule rotates any signal turns 3 as we
will now see because don't forget
disability isn't a thing that turns on
or off you don't just get people who are
entirely blind but fine every other way
entirely death but perfectly able to see
you get lots of folks who might be able
to walk around safely in the world but
who couldn't make out that signal and
who couldn't work out the beeping from
the background noise even if there was
some so that little nodule means it's
safe for a lot of British people to
cross the road and that is something you
might cut it
why do I do videos near rugs that is
something you might not have known
you